And then we also had the good fortune
of having the support of the health
and building surveyor for geraniums shire.
You know i was later merged into
the city of lismore but that
that time the health and buildings
of a was one wally duck a ring
and while he was quite fascinated
with what was going on.
And the preparation of the festival
bent over backwards to help us.
He really made it easy for us.
So we the level of the show negotiations
also had this sort of magical quality
and for the resonance to it
was really special time and.
One of the landowners called they
smith was very helpful to us
and they've had a property
that adjoined one of the sites of
the festival which we leased and.
And the boundary was the
creek malcolm creek
and they've took to riding his horse down
to the creek to inspect the boundary
and see how things were developing
and of course one of the nuns was it was a
lot of naked swimming in the creek and.
David course we asked. We can you know.
Go for a ride on a horse
and he'd stand there in these naked women
with take his horse up the creek in a
slight lady godiva and it was just
magical beautiful women you know
and in goodwill.
All i can say you know just a good feeling
that was so like we managed to establish
the vibe of the festival how we wanted the
festival to be early on in the meeting with
the message we were completely taken by
the mcluhan idea that we had to
demonstrate in everything we did
and. And it was difficult at the same
time and more and more people are.
I lived in nimbin. And of
the ages of the festival.
What we discovered was
that less work was being
that the more people we were feeding in
the less work was being done the progress
on the site getting the toilets and
things made was going very slowly
and exhausting the people
that were doing it.
And meanwhile there was a lot about laying
around in the street so i also had this
difficult job of motivating people. And.
It came to a head for me and it was an
issue that's been that has dogged him
and ever since like the role
of gatekeeping. How do you.
How do you get people to agree on standards
of behaviour when everything is free.
You know. And.
It was personified for me in the arrival
of a particular woman who was which right
and i do not use this word lightly.
She had been brought to town by a
guy who was dabbling in the occult.
And he he had a house a
property over in the coast.
Byron bay way and this woman was
obviously too much and he'd just up
and say well take it a name
and look after your name
and so he literally drove up and pushed
out of the car and left it there.
She was dressed she used
to wear a very short skirt
and in one hand she clutched at a dirty
rag doll much much handled ragdoll she
would have been.
Mid-40s with a hard to say face blown
up by excessive consumption of alcohol
and on the other hand she
clasped bottle. And.
She was a woman of some power
parent she'd been an actress
and she had timing was
immaculate she knew what to say
and how to say it in a way that really
shocked people went to the roof
and it wasn't too long before she was
thrown out of the nimbin pub. And.
And the story is
that the loggers in the niman pub who are
course fascinated by these women hanging
around i mean is this a town.
That didn't have too many young women
suddenly inundated with single women.
He she they were staring at her
and she's just tennis what you want to
fuck with confronting them with the truth.
So they checked around but
that didn't stop her from getting alcohol
so she arranged for other people to buy
booze
and she would lie in the street with a dress
up around the crutch drunk in abusing
people as they were passed.
For me this is a crisis.
You know in our community liaison process
quite apart from setting examples still
expecting to be fed by the festival.
You know to encourage people not to work
and she had a whole following around
you know. So we don't want you know.
It's all just happening man it's all just
happening in the third just happening
and you're just happening and. Festivals
just happening shut up and leave us alone.
So what happened.
You know i try to nail and
say well we can't feed you
and she's fixed me with the
beady eyes and let me know
that i was a double whammy then i
was suffering from overwork at
that time we were working
seven hour seven day weeks
and you know 10 hour days to
go. We had to reinvent the.
The sabbath give us health risk. You know.
Everything was up for invention at this
time we discovered the sabbath was a very
good idea. Take a day off
every seven days and i struck
and i remember being walked around the house
who are staying by my friends you know
and i was totally obsessed. And
grey and only one small problem.
You know i think of all the good things
that happen in remember all this
but it was like. I just had the pride of
the mind. So it was a kind of my fix.
First hexing. You know i guess.
The whole thing about the
aquarius best of all was that.
From the point of view of a university
student studying sociology we had lots of
wonderful ideas.
The practice of being on the street
implementing those ideas with the know
that total reality you're
dealing with people
that didn't have the ideas necessarily had
lots of other working ideas they didn't
associate
or do the university was like a privileged
environment to develop ideas they were
there were fences around i'd
forgotten about the fences
and fences you had so many years
school and pass exams all
that kind of stuff before you were
allowed to join the conversation.
I'd forgotten about that
and i discovered this whole other reality
world community where all kinds of people
turned up and had to deal
with all kinds of energy so
that was my first
confrontation with hexing.
And we managed to solve
that one by going around the people asking
if they you know respect was going on
respect for the locals and everyone who
cared about the festival development go
and talk to this woman and suggest
that she not the so offensive to
the townspeople and it worked.
What happened was that she.
She changed name to angelica.
And disappeared off the street she went
and lived by the time we'd secured the
lease on the festival site and she went
and lived on the festival site and
ceased to be an agitation to the.
The festival production.
So they were the invention all the other
ventures like tipple have tell you another
story about angelica was
that there was a band over
and then be coaching cogan at the time
and they represented the the settlers
who had settled in the main valley.
We'd gone to main in
search of the property
but we've been told clearly by some of the
settlers they didn't want to know about
any festival happening in their
value thank you very much.
They live very quietly
and they were growing their dope
very quietly thank you very much
and didn't want the publicity.
But nevertheless we had a lot of supporters
who like the idea of the festival
and cogan offered to
give us a free concert
and i traveled all the way from about
50 kilometers around the back roads.
To give this concert.
Now there was a the debate about
equality and structure was ongoing.
I mean how do you run this organized
everything was up the grabs
and we've had previous conversation
about this where you know.
There'd be no division between performer
and audience like anyone
could be a performer and.
It happened this night that this woman
i spoke of before the witch decided
that she want to sing too. And when
the band sort of rough and said no.
We worked and i think
we don't really help.
She got up on stage and
wander around a bit
and people ignored until she got
one of the microphone leads
and again strangling the drama.
And stopped me walked off
and she set down the drum
and started playing a self you know. I think
you know. And anyway. Talk about hex.
They they came to nimbin in three
cars and on the way back from
that they had a three car collision
they ran into each other right there.
This one yet.
I don't own other occasion i remember
using the name who were a great debate.
Erupted about.
Structure and about who had the right
to be on the stage as a performer
and who hadn't. And escorted by all the
audience got up and got on the stage right.
We had everyone is a performer and.
Such was the dynamic is yes it was just
spontaneous everyone got up and then
and then we tried that for a
while and that didn't work so.
That's where the debates.
Yes. 20.
Well it was hiccup mainly for the septic
tank system in the public toilet.
We made anzac day sort of
a festival planning day
and we called people in all the people
involved in producing things as many people
to get there as possible to come
for a meeting about the festival.
So we had a lot of people in town and in
fact it was a mini festival and itself
and.
Nimbin is one of those country towns
that made a major contribution
in blood to both wars and.
One of the things i
when i was reading about the history of
nimbin there are photographs of men from
the tweed valley sitting on the wharf
for people who don't know this area.
It's a riverport.
Told them the northern rivers
and most of the towns the major towns were
settled originally as timber towns to
see the getting towns and its
river ports and more lumber.
With the river port for the tweed
and it was like the wharf was stacked
with the young men being sent off to the
first world war
and they had the feeling this war from
which they exported all the butter
and all of the dairy produce
and the timber all the produce
from the valley was also now.
Exporting its manpower as young men to
go on for fighting this foreign war.
And and they were doing this.
It's obvious to me from the reading because
they were really proud of what they
achieved the settlement.
But the settlement of
that area we're talking about nine hundred
fourteen something would have been only
30 years old.
I mean
that time they'd cleared the forest built
their farms establish a farm economy
and built the towns and the
homes and the churches
and they had a lot to be proud for
that they had brought western civilization
the best of it to this untamed country.
The big scrub it.
It was as if they had you know
by sheer will and this and
that created this community
up here and the proof
that they were part of the empire
and its great future they sent
these young men off to war
and of course they were slaughtered
and i think this my understanding of
this period the spirit went out of it.
And the war memorial speak a lot about
guilt more than glory in this area
and again the second world war
and the aquarius festival
acquired the the nimbin.
Ourself club return services league club.
The $500 and we were using that as the
festival office and when we cleaned up.
To move in there we discovered all
these photographs of you know
that had been reproduced of
all the men from the village
that it served in the
second world war as well
and we had those arranged on the wall.
You know so we're quite conscious of the
war legacy ourselves something we come
and claim the photographs and
put them in story and then.
I had an inquiry a couple of years ago.
Lost no one knows where they are least
we hope we had a modest play. And.
So.
The end of day parade became of special
significance to the nimbin people because
it represented their culture
and what they were proud of
and exist they had so many strangers in
town from the aquarius the still always
talk about the new age and creating this
new culture they put on quite a show.
And we were there to witness the parade
and they went in the parade into the town
hall for the service stands actiq service
and it just at
that moment the septic tank which was much
overloaded by all these visitors in town
blew up and raw sewage ran down
the hill beside the church
and the whole of your side.
The whole and the whole town
stank of thirds that week.
So was.
I'm.
No no no there's lose a
lot of respect for that
but the townspeople is a much so proudly.
Certainly no heckling
or anything like that.
So we approached the
festival and of course.
The closer we got to the more intense it
became the negotiations the work we're
going to but by the time we got
the fence that festival johnny
and i were sort of basket cases.
Johnny allen lost his voice and john
allen is. Has a beautiful tongue.
And beautiful voice. You could spin
tales and get people's agreement.
He couldn't speak. And i couldn't hear.
I was people overload
people would talk to me.
I literally could not hear what they're
saying i just see their lips moving nothing
no meaning went into the brain. I was that
i just had too many so i gotta say that.
By the time the festival began. I was in
no state to enjoy anything except sleep.
And julie and i had made this pact that
when the festival began we
would retire as organizers
and other people take over the
organization of the festival
and let me say it worked.
You know we just literally walked out
of the office and then people arose
and picked up the chills we had a daily
newsletter calling for volunteers.
But one of the major chores
was to keep the toilets clean
and supplied with toilet paper and
lined out and all that kind of stuff.
These were sort of holes in the
ground uni sexual toilets.
You know like this was a great spiritual
breakthrough for some people.
Defecate in mixed company but they're
not all the toilets right there.
But there are some that were deliberately
left that kind of option. Anyway.
Servicing the toilet and keeping
them the things claimed.
The major issue and what happened was
that a woman offered her services she was
a labor organizer for civil and civic.
Civil construction. She got some c.b.
Radios from the state emergency service
and teller team of people who
used to walk around report in
and she'd organize the
supplies she was wonderful.
She did that for about four days
then she walked out of the office.
So when else picked up the task so
that so the festival
maintenance work was kept on.
I i also we had a free press.
We had a lithographic press that used to
produce pamphlets at the back and people.
Anyone can produce a
pamphlet. And distributed.
Bush video with their in
theory videoing the festival
and reducing the first cable network who
we got one monitor in a shop front by the
end of the festival but they put
lots of interesting half in splash
and white video was taken at the
time. Oh well one of the phenomena.
I remember was that. Remember
that one of the reasons for going to
neiman was to get away from the authority
structures right now. I was
so into living in them.
By the time the festival and
because we were dealing on.
Sort of a personal basis with the
police and being totally open with us.
I mean we struck a deal with the the head
of the cia fbi about drugs he came up to
us and said this is how old.
Frederick slated to be the mayor of this
more any said look i understand there are
going to be drugs at this festival.
I don't want to be embarrassed by the drugs
at this festival so keep them off the
streets. So that was our pact that the
police wouldn't go into the fields.
And arrest people for drugs
and we'll make sure the drugs weren't
a part of the street scene in them.
So i was finding the police very cooperative
because we've had the support of bob
marsh and the local policeman.
But as people arrive for the
festival from the university.
You know like this is when the. First of
all began in earnest and the trains and.
We had heard all these complaints from the
left wingers arriving who all they could
see that arriving town all they
could see was policemen i say
when i actually went down to a camp
of a particularly radical group
and this is what they told us we thought
we thought we were coming to a free zone
you know and we will be seen as police
everywhere. Police. I mean bob.
It was a completely different vision. You
know. Having been part of the community.
So to say about memories of the
festival. Apart from exhaustion.
Yeah and this this this
issue of authority arose.
Yes there was an arrest
and the situation was
that the police had gone on
the site without telling us.
And arrested a. Heroin
user. It was a smack.
It's kind of prophetic too. We didn't believe
smack would come to the festival but.
Smack it everywhere and out
and as a ring the rest the up through
through the festival like they
passed or coming up the road
and it was only about 20 paces or 50.
The most 50 metres from a soundstage
and people just ran to the soundstage
and said it's a police bust you know.
And the festival was so together as the
community like people just rose as one
and ran to the police the paddy wagon
and liberated the the prisoner.
And. In the in the melee a
policeman's gun was stolen.
And.
This of course hit a raw nerve we had the
situation of the media not knowing what
this festival was about and
suddenly it. It had a story.
And it hit the afternoon dailies.
In sydney as you know typical you
know hippies rioting and steel gun.
So there was a lot of soul searching
that happened in the festival
that time was a big meeting the
next day to talk about it.
And there were a whole group of people who
wanted you know action taken against the
police they wanted to march on the
playstation like kind of stuff
and they interrupt our festival and there
are people who are suing for peace.
You want the gun returned and the
thing forgotten not not forgotten.
To go on with the intent of the festival
which was to discover a community to step
in the future rather than to
slip back into antagonism
and define the festival
in terms of opposition.
Now the issue became increasingly urgent
because what the police response in sydney
was to send up the twenty first division
which is of the tactical response squad
that of the times.
These were the policemen's policemen
they were there to bash people who bash
placement basically and
they arrived in town.
With the brief we soon became aware
to bust the festival. And within.
Sort of an hour of arriving
in taking up duties in them
and they were busting people in the main
street people who've been sitting you know.
The festival this magical place where all
kinds of performance were having the
street
and people would sit around in the streets
of member not part of the magic of the
festival on certainly the head of the
21st division was saying you have no more
rights in the streets of them
and you would have pitched rate if you sit
down in the street. You'll be arrested.
What.
Anyway we came clear to us that
something worse was happening. And.
So i went down the police
station and demanded a meeting.
Between the superintendent.
There's more police the regional police
and the head of the twenty first division
and the people from i guess so the meeting
was set for 6:00 pm that evening.
And this is the first day the
twenty first division were in town
and we thought we'd be clever. If we had a
local person there. This would be wise.
So we invited. Dave smith. To come the
property owner i mentioned before.
Quite apart from being
an old name and family.
They was also the organiser for the
country party in the area. So we invited.
They have to come to the meeting which
took place in the police station
and we sat around and i remembered.
Johnny allen with his long hair.
Poncho with a headband and a u.s.
President and the administrative officer
and dave smith talking to these two senior
policeman who can only say you have no
special rights if you break the law.
We have to act on it but this time the
gun and then returned by the way.
And.
We talk and talk and get
and i was like talking to because
these guys weren't going to budge.
They were going to bust the
festival this was their aim and.
Eventually we asked dave
smith and said dave.
What do you think about this you know.
We think if the police go onto the field
tonight when you know there'll be mayhem.
There are lots of kids in
this crowd and you'll have.
Stampedes and people like this
and they smith reply was a classic he
said i think if you go into the crowds
tonight if you go into the fields.
There'll be property damage.
And it just went clunk right.
Both policemen realize
that if they did what they were planning
to do they would have some local farmer
saying we told them not to on
television. So they went. And.
Ok i will review the situation tomorrow.
So we stepped outside of this meeting
and in the yard of the first place.
Station this by this time it was dark.
Where at least 60 uniformed police
waiting for their instructions
that they'd rosted people on from all
around the place this mighty task force it
was going to do over the first
of all and it was averted.
Not only didn't they raid the.
The festival go into the
fields and arrest people
that night they became the 21st division
sort of kind of melted as an aggressive
force and they became part of the
festival and they were challenged.
There was a sports day on the
last saturday of the festival
and they were challenged to be part of the
tug of war team against the hippies the
twenty first division verses the hippies
now like they did they didn't except in
the end however they accepted in good faith
and and people talked in the streets
and they were just another
aspect of the festival
and talking at the police after the
festival there was at a party.
I guess i saw a party organized
by the police themselves over it.
I think they are same club and casino.
But it was basically the people who worked
on the on the cuirassier still getting
together to have a drink
before they split up and.
Some of the people who worked on
the festival went heard about it
and went over there certainly could
be part of it neatly that tribute
or guys who had stablish good report with
the place in the time not living in them
and then played songs to them
in all this kind of stuff and.
In the course of this they reported back
to us that what the police had to say.
Were they were amazed right and the thing
that amazed me most was the
number of police spies.
He said there were people from the
f.b.i. People from the special school.
There are people from
and they would come to the police station
right to identify themselves to us
because they had information.
And they would be the most wacky weirdest
dressed people you ever so they were more
weird than the hippies right.
Up with a nice try.
I don't know the place
will ever tell that story.
Well after all. After the first of all
the university students went back.
I mean the bulk of the festival was made
up of university students so they went
back to do the courses
and back at university these debates arose
these meetings were held on the campuses
certainly sydney university and
university of new south wales after name
and what right because people had
had such a profoundly moving time
that they'd been touched in so many ways
and minded being open to
so many possibilities
that they were seriously examining their
university careers their courses.
While most telling. This is
not relevant to the future
and their careers 100 do with themselves
lot of people complaining dropping out
and going to the lab so.
The university students went back
a lot and did personal searches.
Other people who are high energy people
who contributed to the festival also left
town. This is a phenomenon
that people with vision energy the doers
of the world usually have projects on the
boil. So like they didn't hang around
after the festival which left.
Left in nimbin the flotsam and jetsam that
the people who are drifting into town.
And.
Were looking for a place looking for
someone to look after them looking for a
structure to live in now
that the tangible force.
Cooperative had been launched by
that time so there was a bit of an
infrastructure coming together encouraging
people to hang around the $200 were going
to buy this land which is 13 kilometers
out of town but that took a
long time to come online
or something like six months so there
was a kind of a desperate period
that followed after this. Still
lots of people hanging on.
I also had the job of doing the cleanup
of the site because i was responsible for
most of the borrowing and
negotiations to get the sites
and i had this terrible job
because people had built lots of.
Shanties they go to mass sticks
and twigs and bits of plastic
and all this kind of stuff.
Some of them quite substantial wood and
and there's a call from
the tangible people
that we should recycle as much of the
timber useful materials as possible so we
were dismantling things but as
we went on. That's how it began.
Anyway but what happened was i go to
shanty the shoulders of being built and
and to be someone living in it.
I'd say look. First it was over.
Got to leave the site were
returning the site and.
I've got to pull this thing
and i say are don't pull down
the day it would stay overnight
and leave town tomorrow. So
please leave it as i go.
And i go back the next day and
if someone different in it.
Those people live but
someone different moved in
and they had exactly the same story.
I was in a totally frustrated with the
track because these are mushroom acres
basically these are people hanging around
having russian troops which i quite enjoy
a mushroom trip with self so i can
understand what they're on about
but they were certainly not
helping with the cleanup.
And it was just coming down to a
few of us doing the dirty work
and i was getting more and
i was exhausted again.
I had really bad side pains
i was getting very short
and by the end of the workers walking around
was a big stick and a boxing matches.
If i found shelter empty. I would move
the possessions out and set fire to it.
And if everyone approached me
complaining i would wave my stick
and say the festival was over.
So so much for peace and love.
So it was a very difficult job. Just.
At the the whole handle
them of energy shifted.
After the first of all the good
energy went off to do something
and all the people who were hanging around
waiting for things to be done for them.
Remained on. Not all. I mean
for a substantial number.
I remember for example before i closed
up the office. One of the guys coming.
Well i can't aquarius.
I mean two of brush.
Aquarius is just lost a lot
of money on his birthday.
I think we lost something like twenty
thousand dollars or something a bit.
Well over budget but we felt no.
I'm not in the business of supplying
hippies with toothbrushes.
But that was a kind of attitude so.
I did like i just got to just comment.
The tide went out we went from this ecstatic
high together to get sparrows in the
streets wondering what was going to happen
and they had no doorway i think the
support and so they really cling.
There are a number of houses
that people had rented before the festival
which became such for people to leave.
But that basically.
Then the people who are organising the
tangible co-operative went down to sydney to
do the organising there
was no structure in them.
So i i moved to armidale
as my partner and that.